[Music]
hi guys I'm Kelli and I'm here with
Oskar dais and we saw the Last of Us
part 2 gameplay we did we saw the same
section that was shown on stage at
Sony's press conference but obviously we
were allowed to study a little bit more
we didn't have to worry about trying to
write up stories at the same time yeah
we go no taking notes this time I'm
actually got to look at the HUD and like
really analyze it and we got to talk to
you the co-directors about the game and
we learned a little bit about combat
that I found interesting yeah so the
most notable thing that I took away from
it was how brutal was which is pretty
obvious from the trailers that it was
gonna be quite a lot more punishing
perhaps than the last verse which was
already a pretty pretty rough game it
was really quite astonishing how much
Eddie gets like a bastard around but she
can handle herself but there was there
was something you notice with the arrows
yeah so at one point you see in the
gameplay that we saw at Sony's press
conference that she pulls an arrow out
of her shoulder and I thought that was
just a new healing animation it turns
out that's an entirely new mechanic and
it's specific to arrows so basically
it's the status effects according to the
co-directors it's it effects you know
listen mode I think it disables listen
mode completely it affects your aim and
stuff like that and you have to actively
choose to pull the arrow out and find a
place to do that and I thought that
added an interesting dimension to combat
that I wasn't expecting I think it
really contextualizes Ellie as a
character in some ways like I mean she
is really she's brutal herself and she
gets realizing what we saw and it can be
hard to stomach and in a lot of ways but
I do think that the extra animations mid
details and like they show how labored
the combat is and that was just one of
the things and the other thing was all
the dodging you see yeah in that in what
they showed it looks scripted almost it
looks really cinematic and according to
the co-directors that's actually an
active thing that you do in combat is
there's a dodge button and there's
different dodge animations for different
weapons and different angles and I
thought that that added a lot to combat
for me and interested to get my hands on
that yeah yeah it looks like it's gonna
be a lot more active this time around
and it was already active in the first
right but we should say as well that the
co-directors Anthony Neumann and Curt
Margaret they actually said there are
more so they're as effects like this era
one but they're not ready to talk about
it just yet but I'm really intrigued to
see what other effects there can be
because I think that's a really
interesting added mechanic this time
around yeah I think it also just gives
you more information about who le has
become yeah that's like the thing I was
most curious about going in is I knew
you know that le was going to be the
main playable character and I mean in
the first name she's naive and she's you
know learning how to survive from Joel
and what we saw of this game she knows
how to survive and she is hardened and
she is almost angry in her actions and
you see that a lot of that coming
through with those combat mechanics yeah
what we saw the other thing we spoke to
the co-directors about was we know with
multiplex coming back factions is
returning which I'm really pleased about
because you're a big factions fan like I
genuinely loved it like it was so good
like it was a nice like a month or two
before the last recession came out and
when it was announced everyone was a bit
like this doesn't seem like it would fit
The Last of Us like I thought this was
just gonna be a single-player story it
didn't feel like a good fit at all but
it turns out it was like genuinely
amazing like trying to craft and worry
about combat at the same time like it
was so tense and keeping it forum for I
really hope they don't mess with the
formula too much we did ask about a
battle royale mode as well and they just
laughed it off they complimented your
sly nature what can I say you just
looked right at my prize but yeah over
one really looking forward silhouette to
seeing more of the Last of Us - I'm -
playing I really want to play it yeah
that's the one thing is we haven't
physically played it I don't know how
this combat will feel but I was really
stunned to learn that it wasn't it
scripted some of those things looked
super like cutscene II yeah and I'm just
they were very very vague about a lot of
details you know we can't talk about
other satisfice no word on release date
so I'm just I'm looking forward to when
they have more to show us
yeah we did actually ask about release
date and they refused to say anything we
we even said could you give us a year is
it gonna be 2019 and they refuse to even
say that so who knows when we're gonna
be playing it yeah who knows but
hopefully it's sooner rather than later
the show anyway for more on the last of
us we have coverage on the site already
I wrote a saying you wrote a thing we've
got this video that you're watching
right now so you know about that but
first undies press conference we also
have trailers and roundups if you missed
anything if you missed that trailer go
check it out and keep checking back for
more III coverage
[Music]
you